ils ont vingt ans et toute la vie devant
eux comme les autres david frédéric et
thierry ont choisi de faire leur service
militaire dans les parachutistes du 6e
rpima un régiment d'élite devenu le
premier temps on n'a pas pris de chance
si on leur apprend d'abord
des combattants
en cas de conflit est souvent dans des
situations extrêmes coup le danger peut
surgir à tout moment
même si aujourd'hui la perspective de la
vie professionnelle leur fait peur david
frédéric et thierry sont persuadés
qu'ils n'auront pas perdu leur temps
ce qu'ils auront appris chez les paras
lorsque je rencontre les gens à mieux
m'exprimer quand je suis arrivé j'étais
un peu bloqué peut-être à commander ce
que je suis déjà chaîne l'équipe je vais
peut-être passer chez le groupe n'a pas
longtemps et c'est quelque chose
peut-être pas su faire autrement
donc si entrant dans une entreprise plus
tard si j'ai une petite place des
responsabilités ça sera intéressant
vous y pensez à votre entrée dans la vie
active dans les civils
messieurs normalement j'ai une place
réservée déjà donné son goût c'est vrai
je n'arrête pas d'y penser
j'hésite entre retourner dans mon
entreprise et vous m'engager tellement
j'ai une bonne idée sur la mecque une
bonne image et dans la foulée
commentaire
vous allez bientôt tout et l'armée et
dans ses jours dans 16 jours
voilà vous appréhendé ce moment oui
parce que je sais pas si vous m'en
prendre à l'école et simon reprennent
pas je sais pas je suis pas sûr de
trouver du travail
et si vous angoissez le plus c'est le
chômage vous en parle assez c'est le
chômage qui m'angoisse madray de rester
au chômage pas quoique là comment nous a
dit ce matin le 6 est un des rares à
faire une semaine de réinsertion c'est à
dire qu'ils nous apprennent ou chercher
du travail comment chercher comment se
présenter dans la patron c'est ce qui
est bien progression nous confie royan
perroquet c'est parti ok attend toujours
il faut pas que tu as dit oui j'ai voulu
venir ici pourrir ce que c'était qu'un
régiment parachutiste
pourquoi les parapets plus choisir un
régiment pour planquer comme on dit mais
saute en parachute c'est une chose je
veux dire qu'avant je ne connaissais pas
donc pourquoi voir plus loin au niveau
niveau sport pur
connaître d'autres choses et c'est aussi
dans la perspective comme on dit d'être
un homme tu seras un homme mon fils
comme on entend dire non c'est aussi un
peu plus pour ça que vous avez choisi de
leur climat non surtout faut que surtout
une question donc de connaître de se
connaître
dur moralement physiquement et la
discipline qui commet des signes assez
rigoureuses ici est ce qu on accepte
facilement pas disons que la discipline
comment on s'adapte quand on s'oublie
pas la discipline
enfin s'adapte tant des les jours les
premières semaines d'un parent se font
souvent dans la légende et sans cacher
les entorses ne sont pas rares le
parcours du combattant le saut en
parachute et les séances de close combat
peuvent parfois laisser des traces
arrivez-vous pc nous c'est ici que je
suis là ok vous mais glisser votre
épaule tout ça fait vous pousser avec la
fesse et vous tirez avec les je suis un
coût et un coût net comme ceci ok il est
forcément déséquilibrée déséquilibré à
l'avant ensuite voulu imiter un coup
dans les partis faites attention ne
portait pas là pour l'instruction un
coup dans les parties relâché pour
mettre en garde face à lui
c'est bon les autres ils sont bloqués
mais sa zone
donc quelques minutes
les héritiers
m
présent le vent viendra alors les balles
hautes et comme de vulgaires fagots mais
tout de suite après ce sera la
récompense le parachutisme le silence
est un sentiment de plénitude
frédéric c'est tout cela les effets
aussi qu'un accident peut toujours
arriver
ce jour là le décor était de rêve mais
c'était finalement une journée très
ordinaire de 3 appelée du 6e rpima
il encore que